for me the biggest issue facing facing
the world in the least in the human
realm with socio-political realm is how
to get the ideas that I think have
worked for us basically the ideas of the
Enlightenment of democracy of science of
skepticism of reason and rationality of
humanitarianism how to get the the rest
of the world to to capitalize on that
trend that we've enjoyed for so long it
didn't come easy to us it doesn't mean
that were superior in any cosmic sense
but we have hit on a way of living that
I think is better to the alternatives
that is classic liberal democracy
informed by science and reason there are
large chunks of the world that that
haven't got there yet they could do a
lot of damage until they have their
secular enlightenment
I have no solution as to how to make how
to speed that up clearly sending armies
in and imposing it by force hasn't
worked too well it's unclear to me what
will work well but I bet I wish we knew
it's hard to know what what the
obstacles are there are certain features
in human nature of people I think are
left at their own devices
tribal people left to their own devices
are dogmatic they'd rather that their
truth be imposed and challenged they are
by nature self deceived it's painful to
work your way out of those those alter
human traits and it's a constant battle
to live in a modern society is to be
criticized to be refuted to be hemmed in
by rules that you don't wish wouldn't
apply to you wouldn't to be to have to
state your case to constantly justify
what you do it would take a historian of
ideas that is wiser than me to diagnose
how the West managed to do it in a way
that could apply to other cultures how
modernization took place part of it
might be technological the the spread of
originally of the printing press and
affordable books but we live in an age
today where we have even better media
like the Internet and that isn't a magic
wand that brings the entire world into
the Enlightenment how those attitudes
change is I think a an important and
unsolved puzzle
I think the only way to make sense of a
nature and nurture his person most
obviously to point out that there these
are not alternatives that you couldn't
have nurture that is the creation and
transmission of culture without a rich
system of emotion and learning to make
sense of it to create the culture to
acquire the culture if you're faced with
it learning it as a child and in the
other direction it would be a pretty
useless kind of innate human nature if
it couldn't take in information from the
environment if it couldn't figure out
the kind of physical and social world
that had been placed in and soaked up
information as to how to to prosper in
it so you need both how do they interact
what happened you have to specify I
think the innate motivational systems
the innate learning mechanisms that make
learning and transmission of culture
possible so something is innate what is
innate is not concrete behaviors or
chunks of knowledge what is innate is an
ability to analyze the world and to
learn in certain ways language makes it
concrete we could not possibly be born
with English on the other hand just an
ability to learn generically isn't
enough because you can take a baby and
you could take a cat or a parrot give
them the same environment the baby will
learn to speak the cat won't so
something you need must be there as well
in the case of language it would be a
motive and an ability to analyze the
signals coming out of someone else's
mouth as being formed out of units that
have fixed meanings within a community
and combinatorial rules that allow new
ideas to be expressed by arranging these
fixed signals in different orders and
combinations the brain mechanism that is
equipped to do that to find the words
the nouns the
the phrases to analyse speech as having
that logic that's what's innate not just
a generic ability to learn at one
extreme not knowledge of English at the
other extreme
I don't believe there's such a thing as
free will in the sense of a ghost in the
machine a spirit or soul that somehow
leads the the tv-screen of the senses
and pushes buttons and pulls levers of
behavior there's no sense that we can
make of that I think we are our behavior
is the product of physical processes in
the brain on the other hand when you
have a brain that consists of a hundred
billion neurons connected by a hundred
trillion synapses there is a vast amount
of complexity that means that human
choices will not be predictable in any
simple way from the stimuli that have
finished on it beforehand we also know
that that brain is set up so that there
are at least two kinds of behavior
there's what happens when I shine a
light in your eye and your your iris
contract so I hit your knee with a
hammer and your your your leg jerks
upward we also know that there's a part
of the brain that does things like
choose what to have for dinner or
whether order of chocolate or vanilla
ice cream how to move the next checks a
chess piece whether to pick up the paper
or put it down that is very different
from your iris closing when I shine a
light in your eye this that second kind
of behavior one that engages vast
amounts of the brain particularly the
frontal lobes that incorporates an
enormous amount of information in the
causation of the behavior that has some
mental model of the world that can
predict the consequences of possible
behavior and select them on the basis of
those consequences all of those those
things carve out the realm of behavior
that we call free will which it is
useful to distinguish from brute
involuntary reflexes but which doesn't
necessarily have to involve some
mysterious soul
IIIi can't claim to have insight from my
own work and writing on particular
political events light like an election
I don't think I have opinions as a
private person but I don't think they're
more valuable than anyone elses just in
the most general level certainly I think
would be that our political leadership
should be of a piece engaged in the same
dialogue with our scientific and
intellectual community it's a bad state
of affairs if you've got the
universities and the scientists and the
the public intellectuals in in one
ideological camp and leadership in
another now that involves it has to
involve modifications in both ways I
think a political leadership that blows
off science is can lead to nothing but
disaster I think though for their part
people in universities and newspapers
have to open their minds to have the
same kind of critical self-reflection
that that everyone must have realize
that universities can also kind of
spiral into a self-contained ideological
almost religious cult and that it's
important for universities to to open up
and welcome ideas from smart people who
aren't in that particular orbit I think
that think tanks and policy Institute's
have been invaluable in that regard that
there are certain ideas that don't come
out of university departments because a
university becomes a tribe or a culture
as an ideology and and they have to
realize that they're not infallible and
welcome ideas I don't think universities
have been completely successful at doing
that either